[Music]
all right let's get to the phones
let's go to meg in pensacola hey meg
what's going on
hey um i'm so happy to talk to you and i
just want you to know that whatever
chaos y'all are dealing with there today
it really put me at ease to hear it
happening in the background
oh thank you meg listen the
what what you guys hear what you hear on
a finished podcast
is so thoroughly edited i i'm like a
terrible driver
and they'll send me driving for two and
a half hours
and then they will snip like 11 minutes
of that drive and make it look like
everybody's having a peaceful time in
the car
um so i'm not a great driver so listen
we're all
having a rough go of it so it's good to
talk to you
so what's up man how can i help so my
question is
at its core should i be doing more to
protect my young daughter from
unhealthy ideas about food and body
image
um or maybe is this something where i'm
kind of overreacting because of my own
history with body insecurity
um so wow hold on
i've got a young daughter i've got
my own body dysmorphia issues
i've got my own man you are you are
reading my mail on this one so
um walk me through tell me tell me about
your journey here tell me what's going
on
i know this is probably got a specific
issue you're dealing with
yeah so i have a two-year-old daughter
so she's very young okay um
and the context is my husband and i
moved back up to live close to my family
last year
and we embarked on this crazy journey of
uh
buying a house and remodeling it while
we're living in it because we're
nuts yeah so while we're doing that my
my family has very kindly stepped in to
help us with child care
so right now my grandmothers are
are basically providing day-to-day care
for my daughter and i work remotely so i
go with her to their house every day
while they babysit so that's kind of the
situation that we're in but the
background
is that um i've struggled with body
image issues
as long as i can remember i think i
started dieting when i was
11 or 12. and who gave you that message
uh it's so it's very much part of the
the kind of like women in my family
there's one of my grandmothers in
particular that i would kind of label
like the matriarch of our family
has a very strong voice when it comes to
um what fatness means and what certain
foods
are about like the morality of of how
you eat foods being good and bad
and people being good and bad as a
result of what they eat right
um so that was a big trope and i have
some really vivid memories of being a
kid and it just like
it hitting home like i remember i
remember sitting in a captain bees
like uh eating you know like fried fish
and french fries as you do um and my
grandmother pointing out
a person across the way who was really
heavy and basically commenting on how
disgusting it was to watch them eat when
they were eating the same food that i
was eating
and then like in the second breath like
telling me to go get a refill of my coke
you know to get my money's worth so just
that kind of um
that kind of contradictory message about
food where food is something that
that we you know my family uses to love
people with you know we
they they want to cook for you they want
to bake for you that's how we show
love and how we celebrate things but
it's also how we we punish
ourselves i think and how we um you know
it sort of
has become like a moral code you know
you you express your ability to like
yourself control
you know by by not eating certain things
okay
i can't stop you there you just you just
articulated
i think one of the great
mysteries slash great challenges
of our time and we've watched it with
covid we've watched it with weight
issues we've watched it with health
issues we watched it with
religious and morality issues which is
how do you hold on to something that
has hurt or damaged people and not throw
the whole thing away at the same time
right exactly how to not go to war with
it so
the irony of sitting in a captain d's
which man i can get sideways into
captain d's
but there is no there is no
vegetarian or keto version of cat you go
to captain d's to destroy
your soul right that's why you go there
absolutely and
when you're in there you know what
you're doing isn't great
and so instantly your body goes to war
to make sure
you can feel safe in that environment
and so you have to point out
others right you got to point out thems
and you've got to create a space between
you and them
you know what you're doing is stupid but
at least it's not that right
and we do that everywhere so it sounds
like your
grandmother is dealing with her own
demons all the time and she does what we
all do which is
make sure she can have some
psychological space between her and
everybody else
and how you do that you teach your kids
and you teach your grandkids
right that they whoever they is is not
us
right man that's hard and now you're
what you're watching it happen to your
two-year-old
yeah kind of so i'm starting to see um
you know because i'm actually
in the house where where you know she's
being taken care of and i don't want to
like pinpoint this one grandmother ever
no
hey it's his cultural idea let me tell
you this let me tell you this and
one of my favorite most extraordinary
people in my life
was my grandmother on her
literally on her deathbed
she is taking her last breaths right
um in a bed that she got in in a
hospital never came out of
yeah she was had lost her sight
she was in constant pain and i went to
visit her
and we she was a hilarious lady always
telling jokes always clowning on people
it's where i got my sense
she's a riot but i'm holding her hand
she's looking up i'll never forget this
and she said
hey i know you can't see me under this
sheet
i haven't weighed this this i haven't
had this weight
since high school oh my god you know
what i mean
that machine that engine was still
running
like yeah hey i'm my body's wasting away
but man you should see the number on
that scale right so it's not your
grandmother it is
in the air we breathe right right i can
work out like
crazy do all the right things and then i
walk by
the mirror and i'm like really
you know yeah i mean yeah and so yeah
i'm with you 100 so absolutely not
on your grandmother but at the same time
how do we
how do we not let our kids like breathe
this poisonous air
and at the same time be grateful for the
folks that taught us how to breathe
right
right and that's the thing i mean i
she's bending over backwards to help me
right now she's
and she's feeding my daughter during the
day you know which i'm grateful for
and so i you know i love her i'm
grateful for her
but i'll hear bits and pieces of things
that remind me of like
all the stuff that i've spent the last
you know i don't know however many years
picking apart and trying to like uh
reconcile with
you know being spoken to my daughter or
um give me an example of that
so something like um so
so this is she was actually talking to
me but my daughter was in the room
so one day uh she brought lunch for us
and she made a cobbler and i don't mean
she didn't make me like a ramekin of
cobbler she made an entire sheet pan of
coffee like a bathtub yeah that's right
yeah as you should make cobblers but go
ahead as
as one does right and she said all right
now you know you have to take this home
day today and i said oh man i really
i really don't need to take it home and
she said yes you have to i said no ma'am
you know i really shouldn't have that
much sugar and she looked at me and said
well you're just going to have to learn
some self-discipline
and she's giving me this cobbler and my
daughter's sitting there eating you know
in her high chair and i know that she's
not
reading the subtext of that right um
but you know she was like so here's what
your daughter's reading okay and and
this isn't
i think this is the way forward for you
here okay
um your daughter your right is not
picking up she'll hear the word
self-discipline she'll absorb that right
and there's a there's a
consequence that and there's actually
some truth to that and that's where this
the whole thing gets so messy
there is some self-discipline and how do
you balance self-discipline with
hospitality
and with morality and values all of that
gets messy
what your daughter's gonna absorb
literally into
her gene expression literally into her
physiology and chemistry
is the tension is
the mom's whole
essence energy everything about mom just
got tense when she held this cobbler
everything got tense in this
relationship between grandmother and
my mom does that make sense that's what
she'll absorb
and then what will happen is she will
begin to create her own narratives as to
why there is tension
right some of it will be clear to her
because it's about food some of it will
be clear to her
about a and b and c and then some of it
she'll just make up
right so when you've got a two-year-old
who's
just eating and being fed great if you
hear your grandmother which she probably
won't tell a two-year-old
honey i'm gonna put a pizza there on the
floor we don't eat pizza
right she's not gonna do that to a
two-year-old so some of this you're
gonna have to recognize
is your demons that you're bringing to
this conversation
right some of this is and that's where
you got to make sure that
you're not passing that on to your
daughter you're angst
through grandmother right some of this
is going to be
you say hey thank you for this cobbler
thanks and you take it because how held
your grandmother 70
80 right um yeah we're not going to go
to war over this i'm going to take the
cobbler i'm going to put in the trash
i'm not going to eat it
right i will show yourself i'll show you
self-discipline i'm going to take it i'm
putting the garbage
right and we're not going to have any
more conversations about it if that's
this is going to sound weird if that's
the way to to show your grandmother
respect in a moment
and also uphold your values and what you
know to be right about the way you need
to sleep and take care of your body
so be it right yeah and if she comes
back
and says oh two weeks later did you eat
that whole cobbler
you can say no ma'am i couldn't finish
that whole cobbler like i've got to have
self-discipline and then the
conversation's over she doesn't have to
know that discipline for you meant
putting in the trash
right so you do the things that keep you
well and those things
some would call that peacekeeping and
that's a whole other conversation right
um i call that just being respectful
right
so if my grandmother let's say made a
joke about those guys that drink beer
like well it's just those trashy guys
that drink beer i might just smile
i might say grandmother it's not because
of the beer
i'm not gonna then launch into a tirade
about how i don't think drinking beer is
bad and i have beer with my
does that make sense like so there's
just those boundaries right
i think for you um the biggest
impact you can make on your daughter is
how you
interact with food how you interact with
her how you interact with
self-discipline
in your home when it's y'all two
does that make sense yeah yeah and
that's gonna be hard because my guess is
you're still healing i still am healing
most of the people who have had
challenges with food with body image are
on a forever healing journey does that
make sense
totally and then i'll tell you this one
hard boundary
there is going to come a season when
your grandmother is going to say
something that you got to step
in on with your kid when it comes to
food when it comes to body image you
have to step in on that
and that may mean you end up with
different child
care and so to answer your original
original question
yeah there may come a moment and i think
it's important for you and your husband
to have those boundaries pre-established
because it's real easy for them to go
one way or the other
where you get super militant over things
that aren't that big a deal stuff is
triggering you from your childhood
and where you just kind of let the next
thing go and the next thing go and the
next thing go
right and then it hasn't come out yet
but a show is going to come out
my son is is was with a couple of
friends
in a drive-through a dad took them all
to a baseball game it was incredible
and my son was in a drive-through and uh
he took him to mcdonald's
and then that night i didn't know that
that night i said hey man what'd you
have for dinner and he said oh nothing i
just had a couple of french fries i was
like
why they didn't y'all didn't eat i gave
you some money and he said
yeah but we went to mcdonald's and i
just i told him i just couldn't support
that
and i was like dude have a burger man
you're out with your buddy you know what
i mean
and so that told me i i've hit the
pendulum too far right that's
that's crazy and so all that to say is
that's my stuff that now i'm passing
along to him
right right and so it's just finding
that sweet balance i think the most
important thing is to have that
conversation with your husband
with yourself with a counselor outside
of this home so you know where your
boundaries are
and then know uh this is when i'm
bringing drama on
to my family that is my own stuff and
this is when i really need to step in
and that line is just unfortunately
different for everybody
yeah but i do love love
love that you're looking out for your
daughter the bigger thing is gonna be
i in my opinion maybe i'm crazy the
bigger the bigger opinion for me is
going to be media consumption what are
these pictures what are these images
that are going to communicate to my
daughter what beauty is what beauty is
not
are they going to hear language like oh
that person's
less than that person disgusts me those
are the kind of things that deeply
imprint deeply and wire into a child
right
yeah and those are the things to be
careful of if you hear that kind of
nonsense at a table
that's when um like when you're out to
dinner
i will i will and i have said hey uh
we're not gonna do that
and i've overrode those kind of comments
with family members with people i love
um because they're not trying to be ugly
this just becomes jokes and silly and
we're just being fun i'm just poking
around
and i need everybody to make sure and
i'm communicating my kid
sometimes people are going to say things
that are going to hurt your feelings or
that are going to
be inappropriate and here's how you
stand up to that gently respectfully but
directly too right
and you're getting free child care and i
know that makes this whole thing super
super messy
super messy it's hard to put a price on
your values it's hard to put a price on
your morality and i know that makes this
whole thing so complicated
rest assured you're a good mom i'm so
i'm just proud of you for even having
the thoughts in the conversation
um sometimes self-discipline looks like
smiling and saying thank you and then
put in the trash
that's so messy